ก็ไปสอนพอดี
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ผู้หญิงคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธค่ะ
วันนี้วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 30
ค่ะวันที่ 30 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมค่ะเดือนมีนาคมปีที่เท่าไหร่แล้วคะ
พ.ต.
ปีพตเท่าไหร่ปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีค.ศ 2022
อ่ะค่ะ
2022 ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมง
ตอนนี้เวลา
16:18
นาทีค่ะค่ะ
4:18 นาทีนะคะยินเขานักเรียนแล้วก็
H ไปเค้าใจมือยก
คอมพิวเตอร์
ผู้หญิงก็ตกใจค่ะถูกใจ
นักเรียนกี่คนคะ
นักเรียน 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10
10 คนค่ะ 10 คนนะคะผู้หญิงคลิปนี้ครู
หญิงมีอะไรครู
ไม่เห็นมีรูปให้นักเรียนเราก็ครูเอ๋เอ๋ดู
ค่ะให้ดูมีคำถามไหมคะเมื่อมีคำถามขอไม่มี
คำถามนักเรียนดูเราก็ฟัง
ใช่โอเคค่ะได้ค่ะ
คู๋จะดูรูปนะคะมีตัวเห็นแล้ว
รูปนี้เป็นอะไรคะผู้หญิงเป็นเองทางหรือ
ผลไม้
เป็นผลไม้ค่ะเป็นผลไม้
คนละไม้
อันนี้
2 ลูกนี้แล้วบอกมี 1 ลูก 2 ลูกนะมีผลไม้
2 ลูกนะคะ 5  2 มีผลไม้ 2 ลูกนี้
เรียกว่าอะไรคะผลไม้ 2 ลูกนี้เรียกว่าส้ม
โอ
ส้มโอโอ้โหค่ะ
ข้างบนส้มโอ
คืออะไรคะ
ก้านค่ะก้านก้านหรือคั่วไหมคะทั่วหน้า
คั่วนะคะขั้วของส้มโอแล้วติดกับขั้วเรียก
ว่าอะไรคะใบค่ะใบนะคะพ่อ
รูปนี้มีส้มโอ 2 ลูกเท่า
ส้มโอ 1 ลูกเนี่ยปลอกเปลือกใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะอันไหนเป็นเปลือกคะ
นี้ค่ะ
มีสีเขียวเหลือบค่ะนะสีเขียวเปลือกแต่
เปลือกมี 2 สีใช่ไหมคะกะเปลือดข้างนอก
เวลาดูนะรูปที่ไหนส้มโอลูกที่ 1 ค่ะเผื่อ
ข้างนอกสีเขียวค่ะลูกที่ 2 นะคะเปลือก
ข้างในสีขาว
5 เปลือกข้างในสีขาว
แข็งหรือเมมริม
นิ่มอ่อนนิ่มใช่มั้ยนักเรียนรู้จักนิ่ม
ไหม
สำลีสำลีเนี่ยนิ่ม
สำลีนิ่มตุ๊กตานิ่มริมอันนี้ไม้ไม้
แข็ง
นะฮะ
เปลือกส้มโอนิ่มหรือ
น้ำแข็งค่ะเหลืองส้มโอนิมฮอทสนิ่มนะคะ
นิ่ม
อ๋อก็มีแกะเปลือก
ครึ่งใช่มั้ยครึ่งลูกขึ้น
พูดเอ๋สีเขียวเปลือกแล้วอันนี้
เรียกอะไรคะเนื้อ
โค
เนื้อส้มโออะไรนะคะกินได้ใช่ไหมคะมีเนื้อ
ส้มอร่อย
ครูเอ๋ชอบส้มโอเคชอบส้มโอค่ะผู้หญิงชอบ
ส้มโอไหมคะ
ชอบค่ะ
นักเรียนชอบส้มโอไหมยกมือค่ะยกมือเหรออ๋อ
โป้นักเรียนชอบส้มโอไหมคะอ้อนักเรียน 7
คนชอบส้มโอ
นักเรียน 3 คนใหม่ choc นะโอเคครูเอ๋ชอบ
นะคะผู้หญิงมีผลไม้อย่างอื่นไหมคะนี้ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋นี่ค่ะ
คนละไม้ชนิดนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะเนาะค่ะ
เงาะเหรอเงาะ
อยู่ที่ไหนคะเงาะอยู่ในตะกร้าสานสอดใช่
อันนี้อันนี้ใช่ไหมคะตะกร้าใส่ค่ะ
อันนี้อันนี้อะไรนะ
ตะกร้าใช่ไหมคะเงาะอยู่เข้าไป
ในตะกร้านะคะ
ผู้หญิงเปลือกของง้อ
ไม่ใช่ไหมเปลือกใส่ค่ะมีอะไรคะมีขนค่ะมี
ขนไม่ใช่ผมนะไม่ใช่ผมนะมีขนขนขนอ๋ออ๋อมี
ขนนะคะนี้เนื้อ
เปลือกสีอะไรคะ
เปลือกสีแดงค่ะเปลือกสีแดงนะคะเลือกสีแดง
ผู้หญิงชอบกินเงาะไหมคะ
ชอบค่ะรู๋ชอบกินเงาะไหมคะพี่เอ๋ชอบกิน
เนาะค่ะกินสีแดงหรือกินสีขาว More  in สี
ขาวอ้ากินสีขาวเรียกว่าอะไรคะเรียกว่า
เนื้อค่ะค่ะเนื้อม้ากินเนื้อเงาะไม่กิน
เปลือกนะคะสีแดงไม่กินค่ะอ๋อกูเองหิวยัง
ไม่หมดครูเอ๋มีผลไม้อีกค่ะมีอะไรคะ
เห็นไว้เห็นค่า
เปลือกสีม่วง
สีม่วงเนื้อสีอะไรคะสีเหลืองค่ะมีเม็ด
มีเมตรเม็ดสีอะไรคะครูหญิงนี้มีเม็ดสีดำ
ค่ะมีเม็ดสีดำ
ผู้หญิงผลไม้อันนี้ชื่อมีอะไรคะผลไม้อัน
นี้ชื่อ
เสาวรสค่ะ
เสาวรสนะคะ
เสาวรสคะคุยชอบไหมคะครูเอ๋ชอบกินเสาวรส
ค่ะ
ครูหญิงมั้ยชอบคุยชอบ
มากโห
คุยไม่ชอบผู้หญิงเหม็นใช่มั้ยอ้ะ
เหม็นอ้ะเอ๋ขอหอม
[เพลง]
หอมซื้อกูเองคิดหอมผู้หญิงคิดเหม็น
เหม็นใครค่ะ
นักเรียนนักเรียนชอบเสาวรสไหมคะ
ยกมือถ้าชอบยกมือ
นะเรียนทั้งหมด 10 คนชอบ
เสาวรสโอ้เหมือนครูเอ๋
เหมือนครูเอ๋อะไม่มีเหมือนครูหญิงเลยไม่
มี
โง่ๆ
เพราะ
นักเรียนชอบเงาะมั้ยคะชอบกินเงาะๆนัก
เรียนชอบกินเนาะไหมคะยกมั้ย
ไม่มี
หนึ่งคนไม่รู้ทนรอคุณลิซ่าบอกชอบ
นักเรียนนักเรียนที่เลยวะ
นักเรียนบอกไม่ชอบเงาะนะคะโอเคชอบเสาวคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
มีผลไม้อีกไหมคะมีค่ะนี่ค่ะครูเอ๋ผลไม้
รูปนี้ชื่อว่าอะไรคะ
ผลไม้รูปนี้ชื่อว่าแก้วมังกร
แก้วมังกร
เปลือกสีอะไรเปลือกสีชมพู
เนื้อสีอะไรเนื้อสีขาว
สีดำเป็นอะไรคะเม็ดค่ะเม็ดเม็ดนะสีดำสีดำ
สีดำสีดำสีดำสีดำอ๋อ
เบื่อสีชมพูเนื้อสีขาวเม็ดวู้มีเม็ดมากๆ
ใช่ค่ะกินยังไงคะเอาเอ่อออกไหมคะไม่ต้อง
ค่ะไม่เอาเม็ดออกกิน bet ได้เพราะกินเม็ด
ได้เม็ดไม่แข็งเหรอคะไม้นะแข็ง
กินไม่ได้แข็ง
เม็ดแก้วมังกรนิ่มเหรอคะ
ไม่นิ่มไม่แข็ง
กินได้กับฟันเนี่ยกัดโอเคโอเค
[เพลง]
โอเคฟันชาติเม็ดแก้วมังกรได้ราคาครูเอ๋
เอ๋ชอบกินแก้วมังกรไหมคะครูเอ๋ชอบกินแก้ว
มังกร
ครูหญิงชอบกินแก้วมังกรไหมคะครูหญิงชอบ
กินค่ะอ๋อ
ที่นักเรียนชอบกินแก้วมังกรไหมคะยกมือยก
ไม้ยกมือยกมายกมายกมือ
นักเรียนกี่คนครับผู้หญิงชอบกินแก้วมังกร
นักเรียน 6 คนชอบกินแก้วมังกร
ก็นักเรียน 4 คนไม่ชอบกินแก้วมังกร
มีขาครู 2 คนชอบกินแก้วมังกรนะคะค่ะมี
ผลไม้อีกไหมคะนี่ค่ะอะไรคะมีใครคะผู้หญิง
แตงโม
แตงโมลูกกลม
กลม
ๆกลม
มี
เปลือกสีอะไรคะ
เหลือดสีเขียวค่ะ
เนื้อสีอะไรคะเนื้อสีแดงค่ะ
เม็ดสีอะไรคะเม็ดสีน้ำตาล
เม็ดสีน้ำตาลครูผู้หญิงดำอะสิบัญชีสีดำ
บางทีสีดำครูหญิงผู้หญิงอ่ะแตงโมมีเม็ด
กินเม็ดได้ไหมคะกินเม็ดไม่ได้ค่ะไม่ได้
หรอกอ้าวเพลง
สบายทีคูเอกกินว่าแล้ว
รู้สิ่งคิด ecru เอกกินเม็ดแตงโมคู๋
แต่ขี้เกียจเอาเม็ดออกตัวเองเคี้ยวเคี้ยว
กลืนนะๆ
คิดว่าโอเคนะเรียนกินแตงโมไหมคะ
นักเรียนกินไหมจิ้นอนักเรียนทางหมดกินแตง
โมโรงเรียน
เป็นชอบนักเรียนกินเม็ดแตงโมไหมคะนัก
เรียน
ไม่กินนะไม่กินนะคะไม่กินนะเม็ดแตงโมบาง
ทีพูดเมล็ดเนาะเมล็ด
มีเม็ดเม็ดเม็ดมากๆพูดค่ะเมล็ด
4 ไม่เมล็ดแตงโมเมล็ดแตงโมนะคะถ้านัก
เรียนไม่กินเมล็ดแตงโมนะคะอ๋อครูเอ๋คน
เดียวกินเมล็ดแตงโมทัยหญิงชอบแตงโมไหมคะ
ครูหญิงชอบแต่งโบว์ค่ะน้อรู้เหรอชอบแตงโม
ไหมคะครูเอกชอบแตงโมโอเคอ๋อชอบธรรมดา
ธรรมดาธรรมดาธรรมดาไม่ชอบมาก
ชาติแบงค์โหมดนะคะโอเค
อะไรคะครูหญิงกล้วยน้ำว้าค่ะกล้วยน้ำว้า
เปลือกสีอะไรคะเปลือกสีเหลืองค่ะเปลือกสี
เหลืองถ้าครูเอ๋ต่อเปลือก
ข้างในสีอะไรมีสีขาวค่ะ 10 สีเขาขาวๆอีก
นะคะอ้าวสีขาว
ผู้หญิงชอบกินกล้วยน้ำว้าไหมคะครูหญิงชอบ
กินกล้วยน้ำว้าค่ะน้องเอ๋ชอบกินกล้วย
น้ำว้าไหมคะไม่ชอบพี่เอ๋ฝ่ายหัวครูเอ๋ไม่
ชอบกินคู๋ใส่หัวไม่ชอบกินหมา
กล้วยน้ำว้าดีสักคู๋ไม่ชอบนะนะเรียนชอบ
กินกล้วยน้ำว้าไหมคะครูหญิง
นะนักเรียน
หน้านักเรียนบอกว่าใบกินไม่รู้จักผมขอนัก
เรียนไหมรู้จักเมื่อ
นักเรียนที่บ้านนักเรียนไม่มีกล้วยน้ำว้า
หรอคะ
ไม่มี
อะไรคะนี่ถ้าตัวเองบ้านนักเรียนมีกล้วย
หอมอ๋อ
อันนี้กล้วยหอมค่ะอันนี้กล้วยน้ำว้าอ๋อ
กล้วยหอมเปลือกสีอะไรกล้วยห่อ
นะคะค่ะกล้วยหอมเปลือกสีเหลืองค่ะเปลือก
สีเหลือง
ลูกเล็กหรือยาวสั้นหรือยาว
ยาวค่ะลูกยาวนะคะข้างในสีอะไรคะค่ะ 1 นาย
สีเหลืองห้าสีเหลืองนะคะเดี๋ยวครูหญิงกิน
กล้วยหอมไหมคะไม่กินค่ะหน้าครูเอ๋กิน
กล้วยหอมไหมคะไม่กินค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบร่วย
เข้าใจ
กล้วยน้ำว้าไม่กินไม่ชอบกล้วยหอมไม่ชอบ
มากๆ
ครูเอ๋เอ๋
ดมกล้วยหอมอ๋ออะไรชอบเน้น
นักเรียนนักเรียนโชคนักเรียนชอบรวยหอมครู
เอ๋ไม่ชอบรวยหอมกล้วยน้ำว้าถ้าไม่ชอบแต่
โอเค
โอเคกล้วยหอมไมชอบไม่ชอบ
ผลไม้ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋มีอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
ถนนใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะขนุนค่ะครูเอ๋
ขนนเปลือกขนนเนี่ยสีอะไรคะเลือกสีเขียว
ค่ะแล้วที่เปลือกมีอะไรคะมีอะไรและมีหนาม
หนาวอา
น้ำแข็งหรือนิ่ม
นิ่มแข็ง
นิดหน่อยเออไม่แข็งมากๆนะคะใส่หีบโอเคนะ
คะหลับโอเคครูหญิงในจานอันไหนจานคะเลโออา
จานนะคะอ่ะบนจานมีอะไรคะบนจานมีเนื้อขนุน
ค่ะเนื้อขนนบางทีพูดยวงไหมโอ้ยวงขนุนอ่ะ
อยู่ดวงขนุนนะคะถ้ายวงขนนสีอะไรคะสี
เหลืองค่ะสีเหลืองนะคะอ้าอาจารย์วางบน
อะไรคะจานวางบนโต๊ะค่ะโต๊ะนะคะบนโต๊ะมีมี
จานใช่ไหมอันนี้จานอันนี้อะไรคะครูหญิง
เม็ดขนุนค่ะเม็ดขนุนเม็ดขนุนกินได้ไหมคะ
ยินได้ค่ะกินได้อ่ะ
อย่าปล่อยแต่ต้องต้มใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะต้องมอง
ออก
นะคะมีน้ำมีไฟ
เม็ดขนุนใส่
แล้วก็ต้ม
ต้มต้มแล้วก็เอามาแกะกลิ่นนะคะ
เหมือนเอามึงอ่ะอร่อยไหมอร่อยอร่อยนะคะ
ค่ะรู้หิงค์ชอบกิน
เนื้อขนุนไหมคะนี้ใช่ไหมคะให้ธรรมดาชอบ
ค่ะชอบนะคะคู๋ชอบกินไหมคะขนุนครูเอ๋
ชอบขนนเท่าๆแตงโม
5 ชอบธรรมดาไม่ได้ชอบมามากนะคะอ่ะโป้นัก
เรียน
รู้จัก
ขนุนไหมนักเรียน
หน้าเนี่ยไม่รู้จักขนมเลิกเรียนไม่รู้จัก
ครูเอ๋คิดนักเรียนไม่กินขนนแล้วก็นัก
เรียนก็ไม่รู้ท่อหรือหรือไม่ชอบ
ครูเอ๋เคยเห็น
นักเรียนเมื่อก่อนกินขนน
แล้วนักเรียนก็
ไม่ต้องเมนไม่ชอบกลิ่น
ถนนมีกลิ่นใช่มั้ยนักเรียนไม่ชอบกลิ่น
ขนุนนะคะ
โอเคมีอย่างอื่นไหมคะมีไม่มีอะไรคะนี่ค่ะ
อะไรคะผู้หญิงชนมายอันนี้ชื่ออะไร
ชมพู่ค่ะชมพู่ชมพู่สีอะไรคะชมพู่สีแดงสี
แดง
เปลือกสีแดงข้างในสีอะไรคะข้างในสีขาวค่ะ
น่ะข้างในสีขาว
ผู้หญิงเปลือกชมพู่กินได้ไหมคะไม่งั้น
ชมพู่กินได้ค่ะอ๋อ
เด็กชมพู่มา
ล้างแล้วก็กัด
ไก่ค่ะกินได้ชมพู่แข็ง
นิ่ม
ไม่แข็งไม่นิ่มหรือ
ขอ
กราบปลอบ 5 นะพอดีพอดีนะคะครูผู้หญิงชอบ
ชมพู่ไหมคะ
ธรรมดาธรรมดาค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ชอบชมพู่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ชอบกินชมพู
โพสต์
วันนี้ครูมีชมพู่ 1 กิโลกรัมโอ้ว 1
กิโลกรัม
95 บาท
อันนี้โอเคใช่ไหมคะ 95 บาทแพงนิดหน่อยแรง
แผง 5  45 ได้ไหมโอเคครูเอ๋ชอบชอบสมพูห์
นะคะผลงานนักเรียนชอบ
กินชมพู่ไหมคะ
นักเรียน 6 คนชอบกินชมพู่ค่ะอ้อนักเรียน 6
คนชอบกินชมพูนักเรียน 4 คนไม่ชอบไม่ชอบ
ชมพู่นะคะธรรมดากินโอเคอ๋อ
ต่อไปค่ะ
ผู้หญิงผลไม้อันนี้ชื่ออะไรคะผลไม้อันนี้
ชื่อทับทิมค่ะทับทิมเปลือกสีอะไรคะ
เปลือกสีแดงอ่ะข้างในมีเมล็ด
หน้าเมล็ดครับพิมพ์สีอะไรคะสีแดงค่ะสีแดง
ผู้แต่ง
เนื้อที่ไหนเนื้อที่นี่นะมีเมล็ดแล้วก็มี
เนื้อมีเนื้อ
ตรงไหนค่ะกินตรงเมล็ดค่ะคอนกินเนื้อเล็กๆ
แล้วก็มาเล็บหน้า
ครูหญิงชอบกินทับทิมไหมคะผู้หญิงไม่ชอบ
กินทับทิมค่ะคือรู้เหรอชอบกินทับทิมไหมคะ
คู่เอ๋ชอบครับชิมโอเค
ไม่ได้ชอบมากชอบนิดหน่อย
นะคะนักเรียน
นักเรียนผู้หญิงยกมือ
โอ้ชอบกินทับทิมค่ะ
นักเรียนผู้ชายต่อ
ไป 7 คนไม่ชอบไม่ชอบนะคะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะ
อะไรให้ผู้หญิง
ทุเรียนค่ะครูเอ๋ทุเรียนเปลือกสีอะไร
เบื่อสีเขียว
นิ่มหรือแข็ง
ค่ะแต่งมีอะไรคะเปลือกมีนามมีหนามน้ำนิ่ม
หรือแข็ง
น้ำแข็งค่ะแข็งผ้าหนาวซึ่ง
น้ำมาโดนที่มือเจ็บไหมคะเจ็บค่ะ
ถ้าน้ำมันโดนที่มือก็โอ้ยเจ็บใช่นะคะ
ประกาศนี้ก็เจ็บเจ็บแม่ผู้หญิงอ่าทุเรียน
อ่ะพอแกะราคามีทุเรียนเนื้อสีอะไรเนื้อสี
เหลืองค่ะเนื้อสีเหลืองนิ่มหรือแข็ง
นิมนะคะนิ่มตรงนี้มีกี่เม็ดคะมี 1  2
เมตร 2 นะคะอ่ะ 2 เม็ดเรียกว่าหนึ่งอะไร
คะหนูไหม 1-1 อยู่อ่ะไม่ใช่งู 1 พูห์นะคะ
ถนน
1 พูห์นะคะ 1  Two
จัดบางที 1 คู่มี 3 เม็ดบางที 1 เม็ดบาง
ที 2 เม็ดราคาอันนี้คือ 1 ผู้
ใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋หนึ่งไปค่ะมี 1 เม็ด 2
เม็ดค่ะผู้หญิงชอบกินทุเรียนไหมคะ
ครูหญิงไม่ชอบกินทุเรียนค่ะทำไม
เหม็นกลิ่นเหม็น
อ้อมเหม็นเหรอคะครูเอ๋ชอบกินทุเรียนไหมคะ
ครูเอ๋
ชอบกินทุเรียน
หอมก่อนก่อนครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบทุเรียนเม้นท์ตอน
นี้
ชอบคู๋เปลี่ยนตอนนี้เห็นทุเรียนทุเรียน
คิวออกครูเอ๋ทุเรียน 1 พู
1พูครูเอ๋กินคนเดียวโอเคใช่ไหมคะโอเคค่ะ
ทุเรียน 1 ลูกครูเอ๋กินคนเดียวโอเคค่ะ 1
ลูกก็โอเค
จะไม่ดีนะคะนักเรียนไม่ดีร้องทุเรียนอ่ะ
เรียนก็พบกินทุเรียนไหมคะครูเอ๋
มีไหมอ๋อ
คุณลิซ่าบอกว่าชอบกินทุเรียน
ขอขอบคุณทาดาชิ
ไม่ชอบไม่ชอบเหม็นนะคะโอ้ยอีก 8 คน
ไม่ชอบไม่ชอบนะคะไม่ชอบนะคะเพราะมีครูเอ๋
กับคุณลิซ่า 2 คนชอบกินทุเรียนนะคะไก่ขา
เอาอย่าให้มีอีกไหมคะมีค่ะ
อะไรครับผู้หญิงฝรั่งค่ะฝรั่ง
ฝรั่งนะคะมีฝรั่ง 2 ลูกจะแล้วก็ 2 ชิ้น
แต่งชิ้นสองชิ้นอ่ะผู้หญิงคะเปลือกฝรั่ง
สีอะไรเปลือกฝรั่งสีเขียวค่ะเนื้อฝรั่งสี
อะไรเนื้อฝรั่งสีขาว
เม็ดเมล็ดเมล็ดเมล็ดฝรั่งสีอะไรเมล็ด
ฝรั่งสีครีมไหมสีส้มครีมครีมๆๆกินบ้างไหม
ครูเอ๋
ครูเอ๋ไม่กินขอ
เมล็ดใช่มั้ยไม่เอนไม่กินเมล็ดฝรั่งท่า
ทางแปลกคู่เอกกินเนื้อฝรั่ง
ตรงนี้นะเนี่ยกินผู้หญิงฝรั่งเนี่ย
เปลือก
กินได้ไหมคะเบื่อกินได้ค่ะผู้หญิงทุเรียน
เปลือกินได้ไหมค่ะ
เรียนเปลือกกินใบ้ได้ค่ะเห็นไม่ได้นะคะ
ฝรั่งเปลือกกินได้หาเปลือก in ได้นะคะ
เมล็ดบางคนกินครูเอ๋ไม่กินนะคะผู้หญิงไม่
กินเมล็ดผู้หญิงชอบกินฝรั่งไหมคะผู้หญิง
ชอบ
ธรรมดาค่ะสอบค่ะครูเอ๋ชอบกินฝรั่งไหมคะ
ครูเอ๋ชอบกินฝรั่งธรรมดา
ก็ไม่ได้ชอบมากนะคะ 3 นักเรียนล่ะคะนัก
เรียนพ่อชอบกินฝรั่งไหมคะหนู
นักเรียนชอบนะโอ้ยนักเรียนทั้งหมด
ชอบกินฝรั่ง
อร่อยนะคะหรั่งอาทิตย์อร่อยอ่าโอเคแต่บาง
คนไม่ชอบกลิ่นใช่
ครูเอกกินโอเคไม่กินโอเค
เหมือนกันมีอะไรอีกขา
หมู
อะไรคะครูหญิง
มะม่วงสุกค่ะมะม่วงสุกมีมะม่วงสุกกี่ลูก
คะนี่มะม่วงสุก 1  2
3  4
A4 ลูกค่ะข้างล่างเป็นอะไรคะข้างล่างนี้
นะคะค่ะไปมะม่วงค่ะใหม่มะม่วง
เรือมะม่วงสีอะไรคะสีเหลืองค่ะสีเหลือง
เนื้อมะม่วงสีอะไรเนี้ยมะม่วงสีเหลืองค่ะ
เมื่อเปลือก
ครูหญิงชอบกินมะม่วงสุกไหมคะผู้หญิงไม่
ชอบกินมะม่วงสุกค่ะครูเอ๋ชอบกินมะม่วงสุก
ไหมคะครูเอ๋ชอบกินมะม่วงสุกมาก
โอ้ยนักเรียนนักเรียน
พยักพยักหน้า
นะเรียนชอบกินมะม่วงสุกใช่นักเรียน 20
คนพ่อกินมะม่วงสุกอร่อยๆอร่อยใส่ค่ะมี
อย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะมีค่ะครูเอ๋โอเคอะไรคะ
ผู้หญิงมาละก่อนสุขค่ะมะละกอสุกนะคะ
มะละกอมีดิบกับสู้สิบใส่กะสีเขียวอาสาทำ
มะละกอสุกเปลือกสีอะไรคะเบื่อสีส้มค่ะนา
เครียดเนื้อเนื้อสีอะไรคะเนื้อสีส้มค่ะ
เมล็ดสีอะไรคะเมล็ดสีดำค่ะเมล็ดสีดำ
กินเปลือกได้ไหมคะ
กินเปลือกไม่ได้ต่อไปค่ะไม่กินอะไรคะกิน
เนื้อก้นยันต์เนื้อ
ผงค่ะนี่มนะคะครูหญิงชอบกินมะละกอไหมคะ
ผู้หญิง
โทษนิดหน่อยค่ะหาผู้หญิงชอบนิดหน่อยกลัว
เอ๋ชอบกินมะละกอไหมคะมากค่ะครูเอ๋ชอบกิน
มะละกอมาก
ชอบกินมากๆค่ะเหมือนนักเรียนนักเรียนยก
มือหมดเลยนะก็ไม่ได้ถามนักเรียนยกมือ
อ่อนนักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนชอบกิน
มะละกอ
ไป
ครูเอ๋
จะหมดเวลาแล้วค่ะหมดเวลาแล้วเหรออ่อหมด
เวลาที่มารักต่อโอเคทรายค่ะวันนี้รู้จัก
อย่างผลไม้
น่ารู้จักเปลือกผลไม้
รู้จักเนื้อผลไม้
รู้จักเมล็ดนะคะ
โอเคเอกก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันคลิป
วีดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะพี่ถ้าบ๊ายบาย